es inédito que un fiscal general salga a
defender un procedimiento están haciendo
mella en las denuncias de tron de que se
trata de una cacería de brujas
precisamente price general a salir
podemos invitar algo que casi nunca se
hace para defender provenientes de la
seguridad de lejos de los servicios
secretos y el departamento de justicia
que eran víctimas de ataques y de
alegaciones por parte del presidente
trump y de sus seguidores diciéndole que
todo esto era una pesquisa política el
fiscal general ha dicho de una cosa
totalmente inesperada cuando su amigo y
dijo vamos a hacer público vamos a hacer
público si el juez lo permite la lista
de documentos que estábamos buscando y
el registro de documentos que
encontramos tiene el presidente
trump hasta mañana a las dos de la tarde
para contestar si va a objetar o nueva
que se haga público pero básicamente la
fiscalía le ha mirado las cartas al
presidente de trump esta tarde ahora
cuál es la necesidad de que se conozcan
públicamente los detalles del registro a
la mansión de trump
nunca se hace solamente fue el propio
expresidente de trump el que dio los
detalles de que se había hecho efe este
entrenamiento es eso que su propiedad y
entonces empezó a lanzar acusaciones
diciendo entre otras cosas que era
posible que hasta que lo hubieran
plantado evidencia los agentes del fbi
en el departamento de justicia los
mismos pero el agentes de la seguridad
del servicio secreto que estaban
protegiendo en la vida al trump ya su
señora ya su familia fueron víctimas de
estas insinuaciones que se habían
prestado a hasta quizás plantar
evidencia dada a estas acusaciones
públicas el departamento de justicia
estimó que no lo quedaba otro remedio
que ir a la defensa y la honra de sus
oficiales que puede pasar si trump es
encontrado culpable de lo que se le
acusa por el contrario como resultaría
la imagen de trump quien podría ser
candidato a presidente en 2024 si no
puede probarse le nada
yo creo que es muy difícil lo que
sucedió ayer que el presidente del trump
tuvo que acudir a la quinta enmienda una
un amparo constitucional que tiene todo
ciudadano norteamericano pero que
normalmente solamente lo utilizan
aquellas personas que el propio trompa
hace cinco años calificó como el amparo
de los gángsters de la mafia que un
expresidente tenga que acudir a ese
amparo y que ayer 400 veces tuvo que
acudir y decir no contestar preguntas no
contestó una sola pregunta
a todas contestó mi amparo en la quinta
enmienda es muy difícil que alguien que
tome un paso así y que sea sujeto de una
investigación sea electo pero el que uno
nunca sabe en el país en el que hay un
grupo un 30 por ciento 35 por ciento en
las encuestas que están ciegamente
apoyando al ex presidente de trovit y
cualquier cosa puede pasar por un
proceso electoral algún proceso judicial
en jogging brown tienen momentos
difíciles para todos